si aucun traitement n'a pour l'heure été
officiellement trouvaient à madagascar
les plantes médicinales endémique
constitue un rempart préventif contre la
pandémie l'institut malgache de
recherche appliquée a mis sur le marché
une tisane préventive dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le communisme 9
annabelle licence on ne trouve cet arbre
qu'à madagascar ravintsara signifie
bonnes feuilles
cette espèce endémique et sans doute la
plus convoitée du pays désormais leur a
dit sarah on l'utilisé habituellement
qu'on a de la fièvre et mal à la tête
on fut une inhalation on fait bouillir
les feuilles avec de l'eau dans la
marmite et on en boit aussi pour y
donner l'eau avec les marmites pour les
l'océan dont le rabin sarr utilisé en
décoction depuis des générations par les
malgaches est également au centre des
attentions scientifique pour ses vertus
anti viral expectorantes les bonnes
feuilles font partie du cocktail de
plantes mises au point par l'institut
malgache de recherche appliquée dans le
cadre de la prévention du coc vide 19
dans la hotte de cette commerciale
distributrice pour livrer les premiers
exemplaires à destination de la
population de nocibé je fais du
porte-à-porte pour approvisionner le
plus de monde possible dans ce sachet le
rabin sarre dans tous ses états en
huiles essentielles et en tisane mélangé
à d'autres plantes médicinales ce qu'ils
étaient
[Musique]
cet ebook le président fnt mais je vais
faire les c'est parce que le président a
dit que césaire avec constituent des
barrières contre les coronavirus même si
on n'est pas encore touchée par la
maladie praticiens le faire prévention
ne vous prévenir que guérir
depuis l'annoncé des premiers cas de
kobe de 19 dans la grande île le 20 mars
dernier
quarante mille kits de prévention
familial comme celui là ont été vendues
avec l'aval du président de la
république lui-même après avoir vanté la
solution préventive par les plantes
andrade joël réaffirme le 8 avril
l'existence d'un remède en phase d'essai
clinique un remède à base de plantes
endémiques à la composition bien gardé
censée changer le cours de l'histoire
il ya le savoir faire ancestral et il ya
les vérifications en laboratoire et
ça fait plus de dix ans que je me
retrouve dans la peau ma thérapie et
l'état étudié les plantes à madagascar
donc chez beaucoup d'espoir ça génère de
l'espoir la motion à propos du fait
qu'on a trouvé le remède a recours aux
navires us de l'espoir et des ventes
dans ce magasin spécialisé en
aromathérapie les stock d'huile
essentielle de ravintsara s'écoule deux
fois plus vite que le mois dernier cette
française résidant à nocibé fait partie
des convaincus sa liste en main
elisabeth projet fait le plein le rabbi
tard l'une ian lee et le char aux effets
anti viral et je vais vue l'essentiel
alors avec tout ça c'est joli coup
madame x par le succès du rabin sarr
dépasse les frontières de madagascar la
demande est forte mais le président de
madagascar à mon avis à juste titre pour
éviter soit de la spéculation sur les
matières premières soit une utilisation
incomplètes ou nocives de certains
produits a bloqué l'exportation de
toutes les plantes endémiques à malaga
ce faire l'occasion faisant le larron il
ya beaucoup de produits qui ne sont ni
analysés ni contrôlées en termes de
qualité en terme de pouvoir médicaux qui
sont mis sur le marché façon informelle
de plus en plus de produits non
homologués en circulation avec des prix
qui s'envolent depuis le début de la
crise la valeur des fameuses bonnes
feuilles aurait été multiplié par cinq